[Music]
hi I'm Colleen hey I'm Dana Colleen and
I are software engineers at Google we
work on Google cloud platform and today
we're going to show you how to use the
Cloud Foundry service broker for Google
cloud platform that we built in
collaboration with the engineers of
pivotal so Colleen you took the lead
building the service broker can you give
us an overview of what a service broker
is sure service broker is a special kind
of cloud foundry app that developers can
use to quickly and easily spin up
instances of different services and then
get credentials for their applications
to use it's integrated into the cloud
foundry CLI so developers can stay
focused and Cloud Foundry operators can
manage the kinds of services and plans
that their developers have access to
cool so what's the quickest easiest way
to actually get a service broker
installed so the service broker is
available as a tile on network pivotal
dot IO so if you're using pivotal ops
manager the easiest way to get up and
running is just to go that route and
normally this takes about half an hour
but for the purposes of this video I'm
gonna cut out some of the waiting time
and all of this is documented on Doc's
tough pivotal dot IO but if you want to
follow along with me here are the steps
you would need to run through take up
started with the Service Worker you need
to create a new GCP project if you don't
already have one then you'll need to
create a new service account for the
broker to use for all of its calls and
give it owner level access to your
project you'll need to enable the I am
and cloud resource manager API s as well
as the API is for any other services you
want to enable then you'll need to setup
a database to back the service broker
you can use any my sequel database you
want but if you'd like to use cloud
sequel you can set up your database in
the console using default settings
except that you'll want to enable
network access from any IP restricts
access to SSL connections and create a
set of SSL certs for the service broker
to connect with after setting up your
project and database and enabling api's
you'll download the tile from pit vent
add it to your ops manager installation
when you first add it you'll need to go
through some configuration steps first
you'll need to add the credentials for
this there
account you gave owner access to your
project and then you'll need to
configure access and credentials for the
database that backs the service broker
lastly if you as an operator want to
expose cloud sequel to your developers
you'll need to configure some custom
plans based on machine type disk size
and pricing plan once you're all done
with configuration the tile will turn
green and you'll be able to apply your
changes when ops manager finishes
updating finishes updating and is
updating all of these services will be
available in the marketplace in
documentation for this installation
process as well as for using the service
broker is available on docks at pivotal
dot IO but if you're not using ops
manager and you just want to deploy the
service broker as an app to your cloud
foundry installation its publicly
available on github and instructions for
installing an app as a service broker
are available on Doc's Cloud Foundry org
and Dayna we walk throughs together
recently and you were able to build a
super cool app that uses the service
broker can you show us what you built
sure and thank you I think it's pretty
cool too
I built a spring boot application which
scrapes reddit for cute animal photos
classifies them using the Google cloud
vision API stores them in Google Cloud
storage and displays the results at this
point I've uploaded my application to
cloud foundry but it won't run since it
has no valid credentials to generate
credentials and create my cloud storage
bucket I use the service broker the
first step is to create a storage
service I've named the storage bucket a
vision bucket and I'll refer to it with
that name from within the code you can
also let the service broker generate a
bucket name and have your code pull that
name from the environment next I'll bind
it to my application and give the
service accounts admin permissions for
my cloud storage bucket now we have
everything we need to parse the
credentials from within our application
restaging the app takes a few minutes so
in the meantime let's take a look at the
code
the credentials are stored in the V cab
services environment variable so our
application parses that variable is JSON
and stores it in a Google credential
object which can then be used to access
the api's we need now that it's running
let's take a look
there's nothing in our storage bucket
yet so the OP is pretty empty let's run
the scraper
and there we have it cute animal
pictures with labels generated from the
google cloud vision API all served out
of Google Cloud storage oh that's really
cool how long did it take you to build
that so when I first started working on
the app I was brand new to the service
broker but it still took me just a few
hours to get it working within my app
and to feel like I actually understood
what I was doing and how the whole thing
worked once I had it working here I was
able to use it in another app later and
the whole integration took under an hour
awesome so do you have any tips or best
practices for anybody else looking to
build an application with a service
broker sure one best practice tip that
I'd like to mention is using curated I
am rolls for your bindings these are
rules that restrict access to a single
GCP service as you saw earlier when I
bound to my service instance created
through the service broker
I passed a custom parameter which is the
I am role that controls what resources
the application has access to for the
sake of security we advise using curated
roles so your application has as few
privileges as possible you can see
examples of this in the service broker
documentation on Doc's type if it old at
i/o and you can find out more about
curated roles in the I of documentation
on cloud.google.com this is awesome
service broker is really great right
yeah service broker best broker best
broker thanks for watching check out our
playlist and more videos on cloud
foundry and make sure to subscribe to
the Google cloud Channel